good morning John and good morning
nerdfighters it's late yesterday night
I've been up working on your pants me
and my team have been working all day
including things like integrating
Facebook with your pants but we've been
messing around with a facebook
application for your pants leading to
some fairly awesome Facebook messages
like are you sure you want to remove
your pants and you have removed your
pants starting to sound like a really
really bad text-based romance simulator
you want to touch the boob you are
touching the boob so in lieu of making a
giant annotated video with links to
everything on this bookshelf I wanted to
show you few things so that you could
get a topical impersonal and stop asking
somebody questions that was given to me
by other people at Dark Horse Comics
this was given to me by my dad we used
to go see hockey games the Orlando solar
bear this here was gonna be to me by a
nerdfighter
and that I bought after episode one came
out and they're having an epic duel and
of course obi-wan is kicking his butt
cuz he's much bigger and more adorable
and we got our bobble John you got to
have your bottle John got the sandman
comics here lotta these are all my
graphic novels my Hunger Games is
currently loaned out down here we got
Terry Pratchett Brooks Mars trilogy
books Neil Gaiman books these are all
dftba CDs this is drive here and there's
Draft all the way over here and they are
not currently making love which is too
bad for those giraffes here we have Jett
of cowboy bebop with his net gun I'm
gonna up here we have my picture from
from Hollywood Knights Junior cotillion
there's a John Green there pro-women
from Esau soccer days we got VidCon and
LeakyCon programs here we've got some
corn dog stuff that a nerdfighter gave
me gotta have a Yeti here is an evil
baby with a duck head on it you've made
Hitler a corgi Hellboy just chilling out
here's a Chevy Volt this is the concept
Chevy Volt not the production version
which is out now officially Yoda
of course you gotta have a Yoda this is
amazing a knitted anglerfish that a
nerdfighter gave me
mace windu with his purple lifesaver
among all of the x-wing books here's
three penguins that a nerdfighter made
for me and then along the side here we
have a bunch of Gungans battling each
other
stuck to it with blue ticky tack this is
the original scuzzy kazoos oh girl still
crunchy from having off the corn syrup
in his fur han Solo
because I'm totally into the
as well and moving down we have a
narwhal spearing a seal lastly down here
we have Jar Jar Binks and he seems to
have been in some kind of accident
broken and bleeding as if someone was
not a big fan of him when that movie
first came out but earlier I was talking
about your pants that is really never
gonna get old on Twitter if you were
following me you may have seen that I
asked for logos potential logos for your
pants and that got to punch a lot of the
more really really great I'm showing you
some of those now some of them were not
so great but the consensus and my heart
go out to vandal Swain's logo especially
because it invites people to remake the
sign of your pants with your pants as
long as you have a friend who can do it
with you which I I currently don't
luckily I do have a clone welcome clone
yes hi how's it going okay
and now all I have to do is this and
then you do that anyway the wifey I'm
pleased to announce to you right now and
we are opening your pants for business
but only for the first 200 people to
arrive in your pants there's a limited
public release of your pants we're gonna
be cutting it off at 200 people this is
a limit to make sure that nothing
crashes or breaks so please right now go
to your pants and if you can sign up and
we will theoretically be opening your
pants up to all people very soon I'm
very tired from modifying your pants and
coding CSS and hacking your pants in
short I've been doing lots of things to
your pants all night long and so John
I'm going to go to bed and sleep way in
and then edit this video tomorrow I will
see you in your pants shortly and I will
see you in this little box on Monday